Chad how many actual fights have you
been in probably five million
Bachelorette villain Chad Johnson was
known for making violent threats this
season you think I won't go out of my
way to come to your house and then I
will physically have to hurt you but at
the men tell all taping told me he is
misunderstood honestly I haven't been in
a fight in like five years
I don't never get in fights if somebody
annoys me I just walk off do my own
thing but the fact that matters when
you're in a show like that you can't
leave you're stuck with all these dudes
so part of Chad's problem might have
been that he apparently did not know
what he was getting into did you watch
the show before you came huh no never I
was like four minutes of the last
bachelor before I came I probably should
have watched more what advice would you
give to someone if they were gonna
audition for the show don't come on the
show not actually looking for a
relationship and break somebody's heart
or you know if you are the person in
charge of making the decisions
don't break the people coming on shows
heart because people actually have
feelings and this isn't just a publicity
stunt for a lot of people this is
something that people come into actually
looking for a relationship in a very
weird way are you misunderstood in some
aspects I think I yeah yeah I mean I
think people got the seal a lot of my
sides they got to see you know my humor
they got to see you know the way I was
with the girl and I think that the way I
was in the house sometimes was maybe
portrayed a little weird if I can't lift
weights I'm worse we'll see tons of Chad
at men tell all
trust me it is explosive and in August
he'll be on bachelor in paradise but
after that well creator Mike slice
tweeted he's thinking about giving Chad
a spinoff are you getting your own show
I don't know am i you tell me we'll
figure it out if I did you know I
wouldn't be doing this get famous I just
want to watch the thing tell you that